after their no I with my good friend
Chris chess explained from chess cube
the world champ ship gang was today
Chris did you you you have a quick look
at it today yeah I watched her the live
broadcast a bitter without any comments
though I just saw the the bamboos but
Madonna quickly so hmm sort of need to
look at the game as we as we go along so
earlier yeah looked a bit earthy at the
positions near the end some yeah let's
go so there without my eyes I'm I'm with
both of them are glad that they're still
you know people around 40 is still able
to reach the top to play for the World
Championship that's really cool it's not
just the youngsters just yet the 40 year
olds still have something to say so yeah
they're gonna be us to everywhere so so
Alan playing white play d4 actually Anna
and had a reputation of being an
extremely quick didn't he for many years
really like very very quick as a
grandmaster um yeah he really a blitz
this game sir when he was very young but
with them with the years and experience
he sort of yeah toned down a bit he is
always is still a pretty quick player he
doesn't get into huge time scrambles but
it's not like he's his blitzing us games
anymore yeah then so okay so girlfriends
black playing black plate Knight f6 and
then we saw see full no surprise now
yeah first first of all the first move
button and actually is a pretty
important thing because well he's been
an always in before player and and but
for the world championship matches
somehow he switched to deform and he
played d 4 against Kramnik and also
against Apollo you'll be mixing in dot C
493 but basically we didn't play you for
the script I didn't know that looks like
it doesn't really want to face the
petrol off or on the night off or
whatever
I expected before anyway so this wasn't
a surprise to me but what girlfriend
played of course was it was a huge
surprise all right doesn't usually play
Knights have sex yeah okay 90 f6e my
play but he never played the room felt
all right never before it's a bit of a
surprise then for the match to
broomfield yeah I actually had my first
fluency of the week and I managed to
lose to a groom filled it in less than
20 moves which I will put on youtube at
some point but I lo the groover is a
very dangerous weapon sometimes and then
interestingly I regret now because we
have the groom filled with d5 so if it
was Bishop g7 we'd go into Kings engine
territory so here black plays d5 maybe
this next move CD is is the best move I
play Bishop g5 but CD remains the best
of most popular move doesn't it C takes
d5 yeah it's certainly the main line and
then can you to get different sub
variations if people ask me what to play
again at the green further I always say
if you want to play one advantage you
need to take on d5 or play at the
Russian system with Knight f3 and queen
bee three sexually but what I mainly
recommend if people ask me because it's
not so so well-known maybe another
interesting idea actually just just to
show quickly I know you play the same
ish various versus the Kings Indian
right yeah yeah so you can go on move
three you can go f3 also oh yeah Maj du
he's got YouTube Chinese mentioned every
massive oh he's had an attractive window
no animal 3 uncle 30 sorry move free
sorry ah tommy 9c free um sorry sifu g6
ya know every yeah yeah this is quite
interesting it's sort of threatens e42
to get into to the king's indian same
ish and yeah black if he wants to play
goon 12 * it needs to go d Fife and then
you can take play your phone and he
doesn't have an ID to take on c3 that's
the prettiest yeah i did enjoy playing
so much it never really occurred this
means to play every it's not the sort of
thing you saw routinely i know you
sometimes go a bit to a certain move
point and then start thinking I didn't
really think of everything that's an
interesting weapon I've imagined whose
f3 was a little bit later actually I'm
not sure was there I think this is
possible but I think then like a Scott
see fire phone before before you get c5
okay but I think you don't want to get
into an opening video here but i just
want to mention if you play this image
that f3 is pretty interesting yeah I
guess got some some offbeat rise again
this but well usually people just play
there normal setup and then you get
something different than the the
standard green fraud okay but on on 225
and I think I'm what he played here
actually looked to me like the sort of
backup variation but let's let's let's
see what happens if all of course and
you've got to take on c3 and Bishop g7
yeah this is all very normal and ok now
the same this position white has got
many options the the sharpest move maybe
or maybe the main move this Bishop c4 do
you remember and this comp of kasparov
I'm Smurf no comp of smirnoff matches
with Bishop c4 and night e 2 yeah cap
off switch between this this setup
Bishop c4 and what so Bishop e3 those to
set up seemingly favored but onondaga
snider three and girl fancy fire yeah
which is normal and hear what usually
tries to fight on advantage with some
rupee one which is AG to be checked
which is actually one of girl phones
yeah headline so to say he was a huge um
actually he still is maybe a huge expert
of this line and had many great great
games in know in the past um if you if
you want to look at the website a
brilliant game search for Gelfand was a
sheer offshore from the black side I'm
thing from 1996 or 97 and with the rook
sacrifice but when a brilliant attacking
game so girlfriend
would be on the white side would be no
surprise but on the black side it is
yeah so okay but I don't like this
should be five check and this is some
kind of move he usually see in in games
were white to be honest just place for a
draw ah because it's a it's a very draws
line and it's quite surprising that he
is coming up with this maybe this is
just speculation of course but um maybe
the team beforehand just said ok if
Gelfond comes up with the surprise and
plays a goon fell then we play some sort
of safe flight in the first game and if
he does it again then we have so got
something prepared for this this is
often a policy I think they they come up
with because it's uh yeah it's a pretty
practical decision it wasn't very likely
that he plays the growing fraud but you
need to have some idea what to do blimey
so yeah equivalent the exchange French
against the groom for trying to get rid
of the dynamism loss yeah nothing it's
not that bad no it's not well yeah
actually uh 96 here which girlfriend
played I think this is the most
principled move and I came up with
defiant which is of course on a bit
sharper mmm what's so what's going on
here with the exchange shock she will be
quicker than Bishop takes see ya chilled
Bishop yeah me too it looks like white
gets the material back pretty much
instantly because the rock hey and so
there's no as though there's no question
that you just take care yes master so if
you can also then is it bishop I you 60
edition age 60 maybe 94 but you can just
take on c6 with the porn all right and
you've got to pieces and you've got
Bishop h6 coming also this looks like a
can winning position a winning position
a winning position I'll evidence yes me
you've got two pieces for of course
you've got two pieces what might get
better up here
yeah at 22 Bishop Bishop h6 escape I
don't see move freely what do you play
now f6 because of Bishop Bishop 86
what's the thread and then whatever you
can play whatever it's just mmm just
close to winning yeah okay that's that's
to be avoided then hang yeah that's
that's keeping that pin on and all sorts
yeah so so what was probably actually
queen I five yeah this oh yeah brings up
the counter threat on the bg5 bishop
yeah and yeah I'd also c3 is now hanging
with yeah with the youth check now with
the Queen shag winning the rook so hmm
quite maybe I must play would be 1 i'm
not sure if he's got something else um
he doesn't want to do anything else that
Bishop see success of it parks isn't it
play Bishop takes c6 that doesn't matter
i wouldn't get anything to do this
without yeah i think if you if you look
at the game will be one black place a
six and i think he needs to maybe so you
basically gain a temple with rupee one
like is still in this pin so you cannot
really yes but but play six i think
otherwise you just take the night should
I 1c3 just Bishop t2 yes of course and
you'd be winning 2c 69 so I six
virtually looks forced yeah so it wins a
temple would be one of course it gives a
two were hanging but it's an awful
confido an open fire even yeah okay now
i think what needs to take i would say
um he can't if he retreated the bishop
then you know the check looks pretty
pretty dangerous now maybe with the
bishop they can't retreat this bishops
there's no way you just take that bishop
yeah you can take with the bishop and
then play 94 even though yeah you get
that square that d 4 square off that
yeah it's pretty fast I guess so now
white leaves two pools hanging by just
canceling but of course black hasn't
canceled jets and can't be too greedy
but he is a little bit bit of a computer
like move
winning the a tuple but why not he won
the 82 porn hair chipping that's the
best move Quinn takes an 82 yeah well I
didn't I didn't do any analysis so it's
most likely that girlfriend much people
look at this then then I do now but when
it's at least it's a principle move if
you get the apron year the past April
you've generated the past I porn but
there is this question about this I
think I picked into there's an official
stream commentary of Nigel short
actually today and he was talking about
this Paul maybe being a bit dangerous
and he likes white because whites Bishop
could sometimes come out and maybe
support this porn it could be dangerous
yeah could revolve around this porn on
c6 um but um there's okay let's so
should we go with the game Queen takes a
to which okay attacks drew can also
putting pressure on d5 um so white
responded now with rook be to gaining a
tempo and the Queen this is this is
technically a novelty I I was looking it
up quickly because I just wanted to know
how far we've been on yeah treaded
ground here home so there was a game
some amateur game actually her with
Bishop e3 instead of rook be too but I'm
not sure maybe aren't already i was
playing on it so near but had to have to
say offhand what's words better here i
think if you consider what he what he
played in the game he just went for a
completely different kind of plan which
actually is this the one that i also
thought of when i when i saw this
position I saw this position and I
thought White's idea wouldn't be to take
on c6 but to play d6 what what he
actually did but yeah that looks more
effective if you take on c6 here what
would be an adequate move for blank um
do you think although this Paul looks as
though it might be dangerous
it's got the target see free complete
just castle hmm yeah maybe maybe taking
on c3 is to really just like yeah [ __ ]
you always need to consider this a few
if black n grab c3 but instead yeah he
played a move which um which forces
blacks play an awkward-looking but
resourceful move now he plays d6 so it
looks as a black can't castles of d
takes e7 now um or no dick just d7
actually just d7 would win the bishop
wouldn't d7 witness with this witness
material cuz there's no there's no pin
on the Queen because you're actually
gonna you can actually the pin the
rookie as you can today a mistake and
there's no escape for the bishop so so
that actually d7 I'm so no canceling I
think what do you want you played maybe
it's the only more could be well there's
also ed maybe to consider brick know
that that's giving the Queen in
attacking c6 yeah so he plays rook 87
yeah Rock a seven ok stops d7 yeah this
looks a bit awkward of course but first
idea would be like rugby age here
pinning than the bishop you have to so
maybe black and just castle sorry one
meet castle and now this isn't that
dangerous is it because um d7 you can
just take now um I assume yeah the funny
look on a7 is doing a good job here yeah
um d take see you could just maybe just
take yeah yeah it's not obvious how wide
should continue you always have to keep
in mind after d6 what needs to get
something yeah pretty concrete going
gears a pre support down and blacks got
two bishops so if you don't get anything
wheel here um it can get ugly quickly
also with the a porn so Bishop g5 what
you played makes a lot of sense I think
like maybe needs to take
d 6 yeah not sure if it's got some
alternative and then the game
continuation looks pretty logical so
Queen takes D sinks now the queen is
encouraged to take that c6 born with
this next move rook d7 so the yeah this
is this interesting now just just
quickly and does black have any
alternative the only only checking
quickly here so move like I don't know
maybe I'm blundering here Quincy said
now you can just take c5 here okay
Quincy's have a quick look to show queen
size five year and it's still stopping
black from canceling all right and it's
no no no obvious way to to enable
cancelling so okay this is this is awful
okay so he just returned the pawn and
it's only doubled pawns anyway they're a
bit miserable in any case yeah yeah
they're not not worth much so this
Bishop could be liberated now on this
diagonal as soon as that pawn is removed
they could be potentially use on that
diagonal but I don't think that happens
in the game but the opponent on c6 is
taken now and now we see a humble
retreat with Queen see some of our black
has the two bishops here so why not he's
got the past a porn which I think I'm
Nigel short comedy could be dangerous in
the end game but we don't see this porn
um well sorry that means give the game
that porn unfortunately doesn't turn out
to be a major hero even though it
surpassed porn here and blacks got the
bishop pair doesn't it look as though
blacks done very very well here in this
game actually to get this position it
looks as though you sold most of the
concerns yeah if white as I said don't
get anything concrete here or they were
the only compensation for them for the
bishop pair he is that well white has to
pawn Island some of those 4.1 and black
has got three so but is slightly weaker
pawn structure
and I think I'm in the game continuation
it pretty much gets exchanged down to to
almost nothing so if you go step by step
here I think it doesn't make any sense
for wide to avoid the Queen's right here
move like we need for just doesn't
amount to much black could just cancel I
suppose awesome and you can castle but
maybe you can also take c3 and I'm a
greedy person okay yeah it did you need
once this point it's gone but what does
why do you write there's time to take it
I think you can just return back maybe
it made me look see to it could be a
problem c5 could be a problem then I
don't know rooks see one or something
like pressure on c5 and then c8 may be
taking us too greedy I'm not sure hmm
but then much is a back row issue here
so black coupe castle isn't there a back
row issue with one of the reasons why
haven't the Queen's on the Queen's on
day one together okay now yeah but but
still this this line make sense castles
rooks five I'm Roxie five and Queen B
seven or whatever you need to obviate
Queen new queen bee edge you can play
rock see and hear our rookie is good
sign cigna because they're actually
afterwards you at that bishops
protecting see one annoying so yeah yeah
okay so yeah this could rebound your
materialism could be punished there if
you take on c3 between b7 it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't clear but it looked
looked okay but okay let can also catch
them instead of taking the c3 porn would
stay weakness so if you castle what
needs to think what about about is going
to do with this pawn and yeah Queen
therefore I'd think it's pointless so at
this point I think what would just wants
to exchange means and trade this off to
a draw yeah very hard to to imagine how
you could play for win here yeah so he
did that the Queen's came off
to the disappointment of the spectators
expecting a fantastic taking aim hurt no
they weren't I'm sure they weren't so
Bishop f4 now to attack that rook and
okay to the rook actually just challenge
this be rook which looks fairly logical
and alan refused the exchange if he does
take care then he's putting that bishop
on a nice diagonal yeah and then you've
got trip wires hanging c3 and d3 yeah
that's not very pleasant the glaze of
the bishop is look at the bishops look
quite dangerous at yeah yeah this also
shows that Blake doesn't have any
problems with white needs to play a very
unreliable for Roxy to Roxy to is not a
move you want to want to play really as
there's no root be one he just take his
the bishops protecting here you can just
move the King off the check so it's not
a problem um so yeah so he plays he
plays Rock City which doesn't look like
an amazingly aggressive position for
right now the groom field Bishop looks
nice so so here um black finally
canceled and some white though with
castling there is this folk basically
with with bishop which yeah ms Bishop t6
okay so you know the only question here
for the remaining I think we've got only
three moves remaining in the game the
only question is but I think we won't
solve it now by just quickly looking at
it if black had some opportunity here to
to get get out more of this but I think
also from a match strategy point of view
I think it was quite content with an
easy draw so yeah we black doesn't try
and try and get the advantage with wine
usually yeah it's it's always nice i
think to have a problem for young
black draw and if if girlfriend would
have seen something really really great
you would have gone for it but but i'm
not sure if there is something about
this looks logical to counter-attack
this porn anyway and so that actually
makes might avoid taking here we
actually the fens his eat for porn here
instead of taking on c5 j plays Knight
d2 so i suppose taking on c5 might be
asking for trouble giving it a nice i
assume it's asking for trouble yeah this
looks so like it like something black
what would play on this wouldn't you
wouldn't would draw i think this is
knocking out a sensor porn head is that
the important thing to knock out since
porn and have that passed a porn yeah
you exchanged a potentially protected
porn on e4 before can always be
protected by f three years of whites
whites got those two I poor poor islands
and now black has got ridden like
weakness on c5 which is the only real
weakness is now gone for potentially a
protected porn on you for so this is
just pure bishop pair with with the the
past April yeah and this is this is
tough yeah so instead and then plays
another defensive move but it's
important to maintain that Center porn
92 and hit here more pressure was put on
the e4 pawn with at five with the help
of that bishop which he's gone which
white hasn't got the counterpart Bishop
f5 so um it's white doesn't want to take
on f5 that just liberates the bishop and
again souls lots of problems that's
that's rendus for similar reasons in
fact black could then maybe this place
see for later I'm sorry not that's just
faith technically I think Roxy one look
purdy seven we've got is not an option
okay so every doesn't make us virtually
forced and now black continue to f tank
city for and white doesn't want the
isolated
onto plays Knight takes e4 one I have a
nice night then and and here black but
it does run into this pin Bishop f5 and
here um they agreed to draw so could
white have played on I once had with
them they're both happy with draw hair
um yeah I think its own oh well well I
don't see how see how white could have
played on but I'm not quite sure what is
the the redrawing line you know maybe
okay to or something trying to exchange
see 34 c for a six or something just
just the first idea that came to mind
but my exchange of prisoners limbs which
talks about sides exchanging weaknesses
off-exchange your prisons it was this in
my system this term yeah I'm Brooklyn
like the play something like takes on
before takes rc3 and it's just it's just
it's just nothing left here yeah if we
take on c5 hit otherwise there might be
Bishop the full check and then take on
before there's no matron who is this
there's not much um yeah this is this is
really a complete wall so I don't think
you can convince oil hmm I'm blame the
players in any way to to ever agree to
premature draw something sometimes you
really ask yourself why whyever don't I
play on it's an interesting position but
maybe this just gets traded down you
know the sea porn is also pretty much
gone so like needs to Lexi pond I mean
so black needs to get something in
return so the weaknesses maybe exchange
exchange of here completely it looked it
looked like pretty logical draw to me
but just by quickly quickly looking at
the game yeah should we do a quick
overview and summary then I'm just quiet
it will be if it will be very
interesting what what
happen in game 3 of course what would
Arnold will play if you continues to
play deform and girlfriend really a
place the Greenfeld in more than one
game well you know one thing which is
some different from World Championship
matches for instance in the 60s 70s or
80s that is just Joe 12 games this is
yeah free shoes it's not very short
match it is pretty pretty short and this
also means you need to consider that
people just have six black games to
defend so you could actually make up
some sort of strategy that you play
let's say three defenses and each one
you only play twice or you play four
different defenses you could pretty much
avoid lots of preparation you're being a
moving target do this in a 24-game match
or a 30 game eight or whatever then if
you look at this matchup in 84 of cup of
course borrow this was all Queens gambit
all the time yeah and but what can you
do with a plate of 48 games and you're
sort of out of you cannot switch around
all the time in surprise so but in the
short match maybe it's possible it's
possible that governed only will play
the drew shot once or twice and return
to his usual opening some in Game three
but a nap now leads to a more the team
needs to spend two or three days no
further before the next white game to
get to have something against the good
40 cannot play this line again so yeah
let's quit quickly just briefly
whispering again so it was a main line
gruene filled with with Knight f3 maybe
a little bit of a surprising move button
as you say it may be geared up for a
draw with this Bishop b5 check and this
defined it's a forcing continuation
really out of the opening isn't it it's
quite a forcing line yeah i think i
think that the draw line actually isn't
d5 but you can think we should be 33 or
something i remember some some game
where we actually Kramnik played the
green father surprises opponent that he
played this line and
pretty much exchanged off the whole
board but okay this happen in the game
this was actually it wasn't it wasn't
completely and ambitious by white and we
sacrifice a pawn and try at 36 ya think
let's let's go go to it so this d6 it
starts to look a bit scary after D sinks
I remember time thinking honest yeah
this is scary but this resourceful rock
a7 seems totally appropriate for the
position then yeah yeah I think a
girlfriend is used to stuff like this in
the night off grabbing some porn on the
side and then making strange rook moves
to keep the position together is the
famous Fisher tau where tau was it was
it someone else by crook a 70 yes the
idea of rock a 7 i've seen in Sicilians
anyway so uh that's interesting Bishop
g5 ok so then we saw Queen invited in to
munch one of the double porns then the
Queen's came off and then we have a kind
of situation where both sides have these
weaknesses that picked on and and and
then you know he's played you know a
couple of you know Singley passive moves
to defend this porns but that was less
32 and here they agreed to draw ok so
maybe they'll be a lot more excitement
tomorrow who knows it'll be a brilliant
attacking game or something smart yeah
of course it will be interesting to see
what girlfriend comes up with them as
wide I think what what's remarkable is
really that that you played the goon
fraud it's quite remarkable and shows
that yeah he's willing to step out of
his comfort zone to really have a shot
at this title if he could have could
have played the Queens gambit or some
rather stodgy opening that he usually
plays against you for plays Queens
gambit declined and those kind of things
but boys come up with was a surprise and
and this is match won't be an easy and
easy run for
for another think unless he miss course
a quick win now let's say but white and
Game two and I don't think elephant
could could return from from being down
but if he can keep the match open a
couple of games let's say three or four
drawers and I'm not sure I'm not sure
okay um alright everyone on YouTube has
got something from this country thanks
Chris okay so we'll upload this to our
respective channels so kingscrusher and
chest explain channels um should be
there soon okay alright hope some some
exciting games to come thanks very much
yeah thanks for watching and yeah talk
to you soon i think for pro game two
will do something similar I Oh excellent
okay thanks very much